thieré bonjour bonjour le vivant est au
cœur de la pensée philosophique
sociologique politique que ce soit à
travers sa mise en danger par la crise
climatique et la menace sur la
biodiversité que ce soit à travers les
interrogations sur le genre dans son
rapport au sexe ou que ce soit à travers
son prolongement éventuel dans et par la
machine il est un peu le retour du
refoulé philosophique alors bien sûr la
biologie a eu son mot à dire et Darwin
au 19e siècle a bouleversé le champ
philosophique et ça tombe bien vous en
êtes l'un des traducteurs Tiry ok en
plus d'être un philosophe spécialiste de
la biologie mais je le précise aussitôt
vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'une
philosophie cyborg alors comment
passe-t-on du vivant au cyborg est-ce
qu'il y a une solution de continuité ou
au contraire un continuum et d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que cyborg sans article de
fini je
précise merci pour cette question en
effet je dirais que il y a pas de
solution de continuité au sens où il
faut réaliser que la technique est une
une activité vitale une activité
derrière laquelle il y a toujours des
êtres vivants on peut penser bien sûr à
des choses quotidienne presque les
oiseaux qui font leur nid les les
araignées qui font une toile et et bien
la technique on peut dire même dans ses
formes les plus élaboré finalement c'est
toujours ou en tout cas ça a toujours
été au départ l'action d'un être vivant
une une stratégie pour
survivre une manière de développer à
l'extérieur euh des choses dont on n'est
pas nécessairement doté à l'intérieur
donc des sortes d'organes mais mais qui
sont pas dans notre corps et avec
lesquels on ne nit pas on a tendance à
faire une partition rapide entre on va
dire le naturel et l'artificiel donc ce
dire que il y a quelque chose
d'organique au principe de la technique
c'est une manière de dire en fait bien
la nature produit des artifices et et le
cyborg ou la figure de cyborg ou du
cyborg c'est c'est une manière de dire
que les entités qu'on a coutume de
décrire comme des êtres humains et bien
ces êtres humains là ce ne sont pas
justement uniquement
des êtres biologiques ils ont une
dimension culturelle et on pourrait dire
technique qui leurit nécessairement
intégré donc il n'y a jamais d'humain nu
d'humain qui serait entièrement démuni
il y a toujours des extensions des
compléments techniques qui sont présents
qui sont consubstantiels à l'identité
humaine et je pense que c'est un des
sens qu'on peut donner à cette entité
cyborg c'est-à-dire à la fois
cybernétique et organique c'est-à-dire
une sorte de mélange inséparable en fait
entre des éléments organiques et des
éléments techniques en tout cas ça remet
en question les dualismes qui ont
longtemps structuré la pensée alors
commençons peut-être par la nature et la
technique donc la nature à bon dos vous
dites hein et elle se fait normative de
façon très
abusive mais en même temps vous n'z pas
renoncer à la biologie alors quelle
place tiendrait la biologie parce que on
sait que dans dans certaines théories du
genre on va jusqu'à nier la réalité du
sexe alor qu'est-ce que le sexe est-ce
que le sexe existe et quelle place doit
tenir la biologie dans un discours
philosophique HM pourquoi ne pas
renoncer à la biologie parce que je
pense que nous ne sommes pas
euh au principe de toutes nos actions
nous aimerions par notre volonté par
notre intelligence par nos désirs
transformer entièrement la réalité selon
nos conceptions mais en fait on
s'aperçoit que l'aventure vitale c'est
quelque chose dans lequel nous sommes
pris nous sommes emportés quelque chose
qui nous traverse et et donc il y a
plein d'éléments de notre existence sur
lesquels nous n'avons pas la main
euh nous ne savons pas encore faire
naître et se développer des cellules en
tout cas exniilo je veux dire à partir
d'éléments inertes nous sommes obligés
de de recourir à des à des à des
dispositifs déjà existants déjà vivants
pour engendrer la vie et cette vie elle
on voit bien qu'elle n'est jamais stable
que c'est un un processus qui nous
emporte ou en tout cas qui nous traverse
qui nous prend qui nous constitue et qui
nous dépose et donc contre ça on a beau
protester on a beau s'efforcer euh et
bien on n peut pas grand-chose et et je
crois que c'est important de prendre en
compte cet élément de résistance cet
élément d'impuissance mais également
cette spontanéité du vivant en fait
donc la nature se fait abusivement
normative mais parce que la nature est
essentiellement normative en dépit du
fait que nous soyons des êtres de
culture nous soyons des êtres de pensée
et bien euh nous appartenons aussi à
cette grande aventure du vivant euh dont
nous sommes une une forme un dépôt ou
euh et dont la technique serait donc une
extension absolument voilà alors euh
après on peut faire avec Berkson une
distinction justement entre des
techniques qui seraient presque
organiques la toile d'araignée que
j'évoqué et puis une technique qui
serait le produit de l'intelligence le
produit d'une projection extérieure et
moins arrimé à l'organisme et donc on n
pas se se méfier comme on le fait quand
même souvent de l'intelligence
artificielle de la technique qui vient
dominer les hommes est-ce que cette
césure peut avoir lieu ou est-ce que au
contraire il faut arriver à à la
réinscrire justement dans l'aventure du
vivant comment on fait avec ça peut-être
en prenant comme exemple le
transhumanisme et le posst-humanisme qui
sont d'ailleurs de concepts différents
si vous pouvez y revenir oui en effet
alors effectivement avec ce que je viens
de dire c'est-à-dire que la technique
est toujours organique dans son origine
on a l'impression que du coup il n'y a
jamais de problème avec la technique euh
et que du coup on pourrait dire que le
simple fait de porter des lunettes voire
d'avoir un langage suffit à faire de
nous des êtres équipés et donc des êtres
déjà artificiels et donc déjà peut-être
des cyborgues
alors je crois qu'ici on rate quelque
chose en fait et on rate le fait que
effectivement le terme de cborg il est
pas juste descriptif il comporte une
forme
de d'appréhension en fait et cette
appréhension c'est celle que vous
exprimiez c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'en fait
la technique va nous dominer au lieu
d'être faite pour nous et d'être soumise
à nos fins et cette cette idée làà cette
technique on pourrait dire prédatrice
hein en fait qui au lieu de prolonger la
chair vivante au contraire utilise la
chair vivante
on pourrait dire que nous sommes les
organes de reproduction des machines
donc ça a quelque chose d'inquiétant en
fait donc ça il faut le prendre en
compte donc c'est pour ça que je
distinguerai ce que j'ai appelé organor
c'est-à-dire des organismes outillés
simplement de la figure véritable du
cborg qui a qui comporte une dimension
d'appréhension une dimension de de de
terreur même c'est-à-dire la terreur de
voir l'instrument se
retourner contre son créateur voir
le moyen deevenenir fin pour lui-même
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus en
mesure de contrôler nos instruments si
on conçoit la technique comme un marteau
donc on voit bien qu'on peut le prendre
le poser le
reprendre même on pourrait dire la
lumière on a l'impression qu'on peut
encore actionner l'interrupteur et puis
éteindre l'appareil sans passer les
instruments techniques que auquels nous
nous rapportons de manière isolée les
uns avec les autres vous avez
la voiture vous avez le frigo vous avez
ce que vous voulez fond système en fait
par exemple le système électrique tout
simplement et quelque chose qui exige
des conditions de
production grandios j'allais dire
c'està-dire bien au-delà de notre
échelle et que pour que tout fonctionne
ou continue à fonctionner il faut en
réalité des infrastructures qui sont
terrifiantes dans leur ampleur une
centrale nucléaire une centrale à
charbon dont on voit aujourd'hui dont on
mesure aujourd'hui l'impact global
donc la question de l'interrupteur elle
est essentielle et on voit bien que si
on y réfléchit bien il n'y a plus
d'interrupteur ou pas d'interrupteur
sans électricité il y aurait plus par
exemple de circulation possible parce
qu'il n'y aurait plus de de feu de
circulation et donc ça serait le le
chaos en fait général donc
l'interrupteur n'existe plus on voit
qu'il n'y a pas de marche arrière sauf à
à revenir si vous voulez à une sorte de
de naturisme je vais dire cette fois
c'est-à-dire de de figure où nous
serions réduits à à notre propre nudité
j'allais dire nulité mais voyez on est
on est dans le dans le pos-humanisme
comment on le mais en fait alors je
dirais que l'être humain n'a pas de
nature n'a pas de nature l'être humain a
toujours été équipé d'une certaine
manière donc mais est-ce que c'est une
question quoi de de quantité de passage
à la limite enfin est-ce que à un moment
donné cette cet outillage enfin ne
devient pas qualitativement différent et
ne change change pas de sens tout
simplement je crois qu'il y a une vraie
question là-dessus effectivement de
savoir jusqu'à quand nous sommes humains
et et donc là il y a une question de
curseur en fait on peut l'être un peu
plus un peu moins enfin c'est quoi être
humain donc il y a bonne question vous
avez consacré un livre entier sur les
presque humain donc revenons sur ce
presque justement parce que le presque
ça peut être l'animal ça peut être le
monstre ça peut être enfin dans la
littérature fantastique ça peut être je
sais pas l'extraterrestre ça peut être
la machine alors revenons sur ce presque
qui dit en creux peut-être ce que ce que
n'est pas ou ce que devrait être
l'humain ou le fait que l'humain ne peut
pas être défini tout simplement bah
voilà justement si on parle de ça la la
difficulté à saisir ce qui ce qui est le
propre de l'humain montre que en fait
l'humain n'existe pas comme une espèce
naturelle qu'on pourrait simplement
décrire par ses propriétés anatomiques
mais que les êtres humains sont toujours
je dirais au potentiel donc
euh de manière nécessaire on est plus ou
moins humain euh et et on est plus ou
moins humain euh euh tous et toutes à un
certain moment mais on est également
plus ou moins humain chacun de nous à
différents moments de notre existence et
même à différents moments de de la
journée euh et et en fait il est très
facile de de basculer de du sentiment
d'être humain plein et entier à au
contraire le sentiment d'être d'être
sorti de l'humanité ou de ou ou d'être
traité comme moins qu'humain enfin voilà
donc c'est cette question de degré cette
question de curseur qui est
extrêmement subtile et difficile à à
maîtriser elle montre que l'humain est
est en vérité une entité qui doit
toujours s'actualalisé la question de
l'humain se pose aussi dans la question
de la reconnaissance de l'autre à quel
moment je reconnais que l'autre est un
humain ou est autre chose en
infrarahumain ou ou une machine c'est
enfin vous d'ailleurs vous vous reprenez
la fameuse description de de Descartes
sur lorsque je vois des des chapeau et
des manteaux à travers la fenêtre est-ce
que ce sont des hommes ou est-ce que ce
sont des automates c'est c'est une
expérience qui est vertigineuse comment
quelle est cette question de la
reconnaissance comment on peut
finalement la reposer à travers votre
propre outillage philosophique alors
c'est une question qui est
essentiellement politique mais ce qui
est frappant c'est de voir justement
comment on va dire aux portes de
l'humain ne cesse de frapper de
s'adresser finalement de nouvelles
demandes et on en a jamais fini
finalement avec cette ce dialogue infini
que que l'humain doit entretenir euh non
seulement avec ceux qu'il reconnaît
comme humain ceux qui qu'il devrait
reconnaître comme humain et qu'il ne
trait pas comme humain tout en admettant
la différence très claire entre les
humains et et les autres les obligations
qui sont dues à ces autres donc je pense
ici voilà aux animaux non humains je
pense ici au aux écosystèmes aux fleuves
aux rivières aux forêts et cetera
c'est-à-dire il s'agit pas d'inclure
tout le monde dans l'humanité mais
l'humanité elle se pose des questions
qui sont éthique et politique et qui à
ce titre doivent être doivent être
traités donc je je pense que ici la
biologie elle est en quelque sorte hors
sujet au sens où ce n'est pas parce que
quelqu'un n'est pas humain qu'il faut le
le piétiner quelque chose n'est pas
humain qu'il faudrait l'anéantir donc en
dehors de la biologie il y a quand même
une décision qui est prise ce qui est
humain enfin et d'ailleurs la déficient
de l'homme vous l'avez rappelé hein elle
évolue en fonction des propres et donc
cette évolution elle est liée à quoi à
des décisions philosophiques à des
décisions politiques alors ça c'est
c'est très intéressant je pense au sens
où on s'aperçoit que il y a certaines
questions et certaines seulement sur
lesquelles on considère
que on doit se régler sur le naturel et
sur le biologique j'appelle ça le
biologisme au sens où bah c'est ce que
propose la biologie quand on s'intéresse
par exemple à nos pensées à nos
comportements ben on va vous dire bah il
y a des gènes il y a des neuros il y a
des voilà il y a des choses qui se
passent dans votre corps qui
correspondent à tous vos comportements à
toutes vos pensées c'est donc d'une part
ça vient des biologiste le biologisme
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que ça vient aussi très fortement de la
société le biologisme c'est-à-dire que
il y a dans la société des aspirations à
régler un certain nombre de questions en
s'appuyant sur des
données biologiques donc ce biologisme
je dirais c'est la manière dont la
société aspire à se trouver légitimée et
fondée dans
ou par des
caractéristiques naturelles en fait ça
concerne évidemment par exemple la la
relation qu'on a avec les avec les les
autres animaux ça concerne également la
la question de la différence des sexes
bien sûr euh au premier chef je dirait
parce que on pourrait dire que dans
l'essentiel de ces déterminations
sociales les êtres humains se moquent
bien de savoir si c'est naturel ou pas
de construire des voitures de construire
des tribunaux ou d'aller dans des musées
d'art contemporains
mais il y a des choses sur lesquelles on
se dit ah mais en fait c'est pas si
étranger à l'ffaire le fait que nous
soyons des animaux finalement et là tout
à coup alors là on a revient vous
parliez de retour du refoulé là le le
refoulé sexuel le refoulet biologique
nous revient en pleine phase
c'est-à-dire on se dit mais au fond pour
régler la question de nos affaires de
sexe de genre de relation au sein de la
société il nous faut nous appuyer sur
une base biologique et naturel la nature
n'est pas prescriptive mais en même
temps on peut pas non plus complètement
se débarrasser de l'idée que il y a des
sexes il y a des sexes peut-être pas
deux peut-être je sais pas il y a
combien de sexes il y a combien de sexes
en fait ce qui est très intéressant sur
cette question de définir le sexe c'est
que finalement on on croit très bien
savoir ce que c'est on a le sentiment
que la science elle confirme ce qu'on
sait dans le sens commun voilà donc ça
c'est c'est déjà frappant on pense qu'il
y a deux sexes et puis la biologie elle
vient et puis elle nous montre
queeffectivement il y a bien deux sexes
la manière dont nous conceptualisons le
sexe les sexes elle est récente elle est
récente et elle n'a pas toujours eu lieu
au 16e on parlait de la théorie des
humeurs qui nous vient de l'Antiquité et
cetera donc oui mais on parlait quand
même d'hom de femm aussi c'est le sex ça
fait signe vers des réalités très
différentes oui alors justement sur
cette question quand Simone de beauauoir
dans le 2è sexe dit on ne n'est pas
femme on le devient qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire et est-ce que ça s'applique
aussi à on ne n'est pas homme on le
devient qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
concernant la manière dont on doit
comprendre les termes femm et homme
autrement dit est-ce que femme c'est la
femelle de l'espèce et homme le mal de
l'espèce est-ce que c'est juste ça parce
que à ce moment-là vous comprenez en
fonction de ce qu'on va entendre par là
le sens de la phrase de
beauoir change
euh est-ce que être femme c'est être une
femelle et donc il faut attendre la la
la capacité reproductive pour être
vraiment femme voyez enfin c'est pas
c'est pas ça qu'elle voulait dire sans
doute
on est d'accord donc ce qui est clair
ici c'est que euh par homme et femme on
entend autre chose que mâle et femelle
ce qui est difficile à comprendre parce
qu'en fait on entend aussi pas autre
chose que ça euh mais euh ce sexe dont
on parle quand on voit des personnes
dans la rue on leur attribue
spontanément on va dire un genre on dit
donc mais de fait on n'a pas accès à
aucun déterminant biologique du sexe la
plupart du temps on voit pas euh les
parties génitales et surtout pas le le
la composition des cellules le cariotype
ou et cetera donc en fait on fait un
ensemble de de de de d'inférence hein à
partir de d'indices qui sont envoyés
voilà euh mais biologiquement comment ça
se passe le sexe peut être d'une
personne peut être défin par le type de
gamète qu'elle produit mais ça suffit
pas par une composition de ces cellules
les fameux chromosomees X et Y
euh mais ça peut être aussi euh euh le
voilà une certaine anatomie des des
parties génitales et de de comment dire
des conduits internes euh il y a
énormément de de de déterminant en fait
dans ce qui fait le sexe d'une personne
humaine et non pas seulement la la
dimension simplement reproductive donc
c'est en ce sens qu'on peut dire qu'il y
a plus de de deux sexes euh si on
considère simplement le fait que pour
faire un enfant oui il faut deux gamèes
qu'il faut réunir et il y en a un qu'on
appelle le spermatozoïde et l'autre re
l'ovule et que ces gamètes sont en
général produits par par des individus
différents dans notre espèce et qu'on
appelle les mâles et les femelles mais
au-delà de ça la plupart de nos usages
du sexe en fait n'implique pas cette
dimension reproductive se situe sur
d'autres plans euh quand nous nous
adressons l'un à l'autre en quoi est-ce
que notre sexe est vraiment le le
caractère opératoire de la discussion
c'est difficile de s'en tenir à cette
notion de sexe c'est difficile de voir
ce qu'elle ce qu'elle implique ce en
quoi elle nous oblige du coup celle de
genre aussi est un peu trop ptriquée bon
alors la la notion de genre vous me
lancez sur un truc c'est trop compliqué
c'est trop compliqué euh comment le dire
on peut dire que il y a autant de
genrees que de personnes c'est-à-dire
que bon les gens les les gens
s'identifient à des à des grands genres
et que ça peut être homme et femme ou
masculin et féminin bon admettons ça
mais en fait on on peut dire que
aujourd'hui dans les études sur le genre
on va dire que le le genre c'est le
grand dispositif qui qui fait que les
les individus humains se range dans deux
catégories et seulement deux voilà donc
c'est cette on va dire matrice binaire
qui assigne les individu à être d'une
part ou de l'autre du grand système
voilà ce qu'on va appeler le genre et
dans ce sens-là il y a le genre qui qui
commande deux cases voilà et alors Adam
et è euh pourquoi est-ce que on a envoyé
dans l'espace la représentation de
l'humanité à
travers à travers la figuration d'Adam
et Ève un peu en de ça alors ce qui tré
ce qui est très intéressant c'est
effectivement nous avons une sorte de
mythologie des sexes qui traverse nos
représentations et nous sommes
extrêmement attachés à cette mythologie
elle nous paraît constitutive et
descriptive de notre réalité on voit
bien cependant que il y a dans toute
cette mythologie un ensemble de valeurs
qui
sont impliquées et sur ce point je
dirais que j'ai pas de problème avec les
dualismes dans la mesure où ce sont des
instruments de pensée ils nous
permettent de nous situer ils permettent
de à la fois de de distinguer de deux
grandes polarités mais aussi de voir
justement ce qui est entre les deux mais
le problème avec disons ce qui ne serait
pas simplement des binarismes du deux
mais des dualismes
c'est que on est justement dans le cadre
d'une valorisation différenciée des deux
c'est pas juste qu'on a la main gauche
et la main droite c'est qu'en fait dans
beaucoup de cultures la gauche est le
symbole de l'infamie de l'impure et
cetera et bien dans la différence des
sexes c'est pas simplement qu'il y a
deux et que ils font ils contribuent
différemment à la tâche de la
reproduction ou à différentes
occupations c'est que l'un est inférieur
is par rapport à l'autre comment vous
comprenez cette articulation qui n'est
pas enfin voilà qui qui n'a rien
finalement de de nécessaire entre la
dualité et la hiérarchie sur le récit de
d'Adam et Ève on voit que par exemple il
y a des questions de traduction
Catherine châlier l'a très bien montré
quand on a dit que
ve était sortie de la côte d'Adam voilà
ça montre bien une sorte de de très
clairement de voilà de l'un est
l'origine de l'autre euh alors Chalier a
montré que en fait non il faut faut
peut-être dire elle est sortie du côté
de comme une sorte de processus de
dédoublement en fait comme deux cellules
se divisent un peu et c'est pas
exactement la même chose en terme de
voyez de de de hiérarchie donc il y a
des récits qui sont peut-être coupables
fautifs euh et puis en fait surtout je
dirais simplement euh il y a des
dispositifs sociaux qui infériorisent
euh les femmes dans les sociétés enfin
il y a une une forme de quasi
universalité de ces dispositifs voilà
donc ça il faut en être conscient
c'est-à-dire indépendamment de ce que
sont les personnes je dirais il y a les
systèmes de droit qui régissent les
existences euh qui sont à la base de
d'un ensemble d'inégalités et ça je
trouve que c'est très important parce
que autant que les individus je vais
dire soient tous différents les uns des
autres et on va dire euh inégalement
apte à assurer tel ou telle tâche ça on
est habitué c'est le le principe même de
la politique on va dire on est habitué à
gérer la diversité des êtres humains
mais en revanche ce qui n'est pas aussi
clair c'est B voilà la la façon dont
nous désirons l'inégalité ou nous
voulons assoir l'inégalité dans des
dispositifs euh juridiques en fait donc
ici il y a une véritable responsabilité
des êtres humains c'est-à-dire nous ne
sommes pas responsables de notre
diversité nous sommes responsables de la
manière dont nous traitons inégalement
les personnes et ici euh autant moi je
suis je trouve que le travail de
catégorisation est essentiel à à
l'activité de pensée humaine autant je
pense qu'il y a des catégories qui sont
meilleures que d'autres euh des
catégories qui sont plus justes ou ouou
plus injustes que d'autres et pourtant
on assiste aujourd'hui au grand retour
de l'identité comme comme catégorie
politique euh et qui qui joue à
plusieurs niveaux comment comment on
lutte contre contre cette idée
d'identité tout votre travail en tout
cas est est une attaque contre l'idée
d'identité des polarités pour la pensée
oui mais pas pas fixe des catégories de
pensée pourquoi pas mais à condition
qu'elle soit pas réifiée en catégorie
d'être comment on fait pour lutter
contre l'identité comment on repose la
question comment on se débarrasse en
fait de cette
question j'ai proposé quelque chose
d'assez simple en fait et d'assez bête
trop bête pour être suivi sans doute
mais voilà simplement dire et si nous
nous
efforcions d'être humain de temps en
temps en fait et si nous nous efforcions
de nous situer au-delà de nos identités
et de nous atteler à des tâches qui nous
engagent en tant que être humain et pas
en tant qu'homme en tant que femme et
pas en tant que je sais pas auvernia ou
chinois ou enfin voilà c'est ça c'est
l'idée d'être être humain c'est ça que
vous entendez par ou ça et je trouve
qu'il y a des des activités qui nous
placent à ce niveau-là et l'activité des
sciences en théorie c'est une de de ces
activitésl face au calcul euh on est
tous égau entre guillemets c'est-à-dire
le résultat ne va pas varier en fonction
de qui je suis et ça je trouve que c'est
reposant et encore une fois je crois que
c'est ce que réclamer un peu beauoir
dans le deè sexle c'estàdire le droit de
participer à des activités où on n'est
pas jugé en fonction de ces déterminants
sociaux historiques sexuels et cetera
euh cette capacité que nous avons de
nous élever à un niveau où j'allais dire
d' différence en fait s'en remettre à un
ordre qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
politique pour une fois je crois que
aujourd'hui le voilà on a le sentiment
d'une telle inflation du politique à
juste titre et j'ai indiqué que
certaines questions étaient politiques
et ne pouvait pas être traité en dehors
de de ce politique mais la science elle
nous apporte justement en un sens le un
territoire à investir dans lequel et
bien nous pouvons être autre chose que
nous-mêmes et c'est très important je
crois de s'oublier parfois c'est c'est
peut-être ça qui boucle sur l'idée
pourquoi la biologie en fait pourquoi la
biologie évidemment la biologie a plein
de défauts elle est elle est traversée
de biaiais elle est elle est dépendante
des instruments qu'elle met en place
elle est elle pose des questions aussi
qui parfois sont fautives comme la
question racial par exemple l' été au
19e siècle où on a voulu fonder dans des
déterminants euh anatomique la
différence des individus euh donc la
biologie elle est fautive elle peut être
défaillante parfois mais malgré tout
elle a une aspiration scientifique et ça
c'est magnifique c'est magnifique d'une
part parce que ça nous situe sur ce
territoire on va dire
euh au-delà du
politique ça nous met idéalement en
prise avec des réalité et puis euh c'est
magnifique aussi parce que ça nous
décentre par rapport à notre statut
d'humain faire de la biologie
précisément c'est pas faire uniquement
de la médecine faire de la biologie
c'est s'intéresser au fait que les êtres
humains sont pris dans l'ensemble de la
biodiversité humaine euh cette face à
cette diversité naturelle nous ne sommes
pas souverains nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de donner les noms qui nous plaît
il y a une histoire dont nous sommes
tenus de tenir compte quand nous nommons
quand nous classons quand nous n
ordonnons et et c'est donc aussi une
école de modestie pour les êtres humains
une école de modestie au sens où d'une
part les humains comprennent qu'ils ne
sont pas seuls qu'ils font partie d'un
écosystème beaucoup plus vaste mais
aussi une école de modestie au sens où
l'esprit souverain doit euh quand il
étudie la nature et bien se se soumettre
à des réalités qui lui résiste et ça
c'est passionnant et et je crois que
c'est quelque chose qu'on apprend quand
qu on s'intéresse justement euh je veux
dire même pas à la biologie mais à
l'histoire naturelle c'est-à-dire au
voilà à simplement l'étude modeste de
l'herborisation de l'observation de
l'ensemble des vivants avec leur
diversité de mode de vie leur diversité
de de forme d'apparence de devenir euh
c'est c'est c'est fascinant merci
beaucoup Chok bon merci de votre
entretien